well there's been heavy fire between
Israeli forces and Palestinian Fighters
during raids across the occupied West
Bank Israeli military vehicles entered
the northern cities of Janine and tobas
early on Wednesday two Palestinians were
reportedly injured in Janine where Laura
Khan is life for us in rala Laura so we
know the Israeli military has
dramatically stepped up raids right
across the West Bank since October 7th
tell us what's been happening
overnight
they really have Darren um in fact um
I'm in rala at the moment it's been
happening all the way north um if you go
two hours up to Janine uh we've had
raids throughout the night it happened
in a village uh called yamon and it's
quite unusual to see any kind of action
there uh but it seems when the Israeli
Army raided this Village there was some
Palestinian resistance we've been
hearing gunfire reverberating throughout
that village now if you then go south by
about half an hour to tobas again very
unusual to see any kind of resistance
inside tobas but that certainly happened
tonight there was an Israeli Army raid
and we heard at least a minute of
nonstop gunfire reverberating throughout
the entire city uh and then further
south to Naas this is about an hour
north of where I am in rala uh the
Israeli Army has been raiding throughout
the night for many hours and um it's
still going on actually in villages
surrounding uh surrounding nablas um
they came um into balanta refugee camp
and um other Villages they made their
way from Village to Village and they
were met with some uh resistance there
were some um some handmade kind of
explosives uh so we've been seeing this
resistance happening throughout the
north of the West Bank uh there was also
a raid happening in heon uh south of
here which is quite different uh to the
usual uh raids it was a punitive measure
against a Palestinian fighter who was
killed uh just after the war started in
Gaza um here with a number of other
people um attacks and settlers and
soldiers killing uh one soldier so they
used punitive measures usually against
the families they measured his house and
they're now um setting explosives uh
ready to destroy the family home and
Laura as we're talking to you we're
seeing some of the pictures from those
raids um let me ask you briefly how
significant are these raids and we've
never seen them on this scale
before well this really is a
psychological tactic by the Israeli Army
um on the Palestinians just to try to
prevent them essentially from rising up
they certainly don't want to see um what
happened to De decades ago another in
happening so we are not only seeing
these raids um but there's been more
than 6,000 arrests um throughout the
occupied West Bank but they're also
shutting down um many of the towns and
Villages most of them have these big
yellow Gates so when anything happens
they can close off and cut off
Palestinian villagers they've um erected
more um uh well there's been um many
kind of uh sorry cities um cut off uh
with Israeli checkpoints as well so
people are usually stuck for hours
behind these checkpoints um when they're
just going from town to town Village to
Village and we've seen this um much more
so since the start of the war in Gaza
all right Laura Khan live for us there
in rala Laura thank you